boys where have you been
okay wait what does Cowabunga actually
mean anyway
the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles are
back again so allow me to remove my
manhole cover and tell you everything
you need to know before you go see
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles Mutant
Mayhem
let's borrow Leonardo's katanas and
dissect this latest offering shall we
but we got a job to do let's go
[Music]
what began as two guys making a comic
book out of their home in the mid-1980s
mutated into an animated series a toy
line and a video game by the end of the
decade with live-action theatrical takes
beginning in 1990 and now three animated
films four animated series and five live
action films later you might be
wondering where does mutant Mayhem fit
into all or any of that well it's a
brand new iteration of the classic
material bringing its own artistic style
like literally a comic book has come to
life along with a fresh voice cast and
new story details so yes it is a reboot
and based on what we've seen so far this
latest version is built to satisfy not
only the previous generation of fans but
also their kids and grandkids too
Cowabunga kids did I use that right yeah
before we jump into the Mayhem we just
gotta take a quick look back at what got
us here I don't get it ready so the kids
were ready for something big from
Splinter and his turtles by the start of
a new decade in 1990. the original
animated series had been after school
appointment television for a couple
years and the next step of course was a
live-action movie with no Hollywood star
power involved unless you consider Corey
Feldman as the voice of Donatello's star
power which I obviously do are you crazy
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles the movie
still got the job done at the box office
with 202 million dollars made on a 13
million dollar budget and while it is
run on the Tomato Meter it's 41 is the
highest of all the live-action films and
that box office payday pave the way for
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles 2 the
Secret of the Ooze which let's be honest
is best known for featuring Vanilla Ice
in the movie performing his song ninja
rap and God it is so good yo it's the
green machine gonna the town without
being seen have you ever seen a turtle
get down
now Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles 3 came
in 1993 and without vanilla or any other
interesting flavors to speak of and it
performed poorly with critics and had
only moderate success at the box office
now it wasn't until 14 years later in
2007 that the computer animated TMNT
came along which makes reference to and
is considered a sequel to the previous
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles 3. oddly
enough now the voice cast features names
like Chris Evans Sarah Michelle Geller
Kevin Smith and Patrick Stewart but
despite a decent box office haul critics
didn't care much for it plan sequels
were later scrapped after Viacom
acquired the franchise in 2009 with
plans to reboot it with a live-action
movie
[Music]
which of course brings us to 2014's
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles with Megan
Fox and Will Arnett leading the
live-action side and Johnny Knoxville as
the voice of Leonardo to lead the voice
cast Jackass success story
now this film made nearly half a billion
dollars at the box office and got some
love for its special effects and action
sequences but as usual critics
ultimately disliked it but as I
mentioned half a billion dollars at the
box office so Fox and Arnett and friends
all return for Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles Out of the Shadows in 2016. now
this one performs slightly better with
critics but worse at the box office
therefore no Turtle Trilogy was to come
are we going somewhere
a direct-to-video animated DC movie
called Batman versus Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles was released in 2019 and I
gotta tell you guys it is fantastic
sitting at 100 on the Tomato Meter but
really that was just a nice palette
cleanser for this latest big budget
animated reboot you're fine chill
he's gonna die
now one of the main selling points for
this latest film is its long list of big
name and interesting Stars involved in
the voice cast our dad is definitely not
a giant rat that makes me feel like he's
a rat but what's also interesting is
that the four main characters the
turtles are voiced by relatively
unknowns in an effort to cast actual
teenagers that includes Nicholas Cantu
as Leonardo Micah Abby as Donatello
Brady noon as Raphael and Shimon Brown
Jr as Michelangelo now the foursome
recorded much of their dialogue together
to encourage improvisation and for
better chemistry and camaraderie and we
all know that they obviously had a pizza
party somewhere in there right look
we're really sorry Spooner some of the
guys wanted to get pizza and I tried to
talk him out of it yeah you ratted us
out hey don't use that word that way I
mean sorry Dad okay so as far as the
rest of the cast
well where do I start how about what
we've seen prominently in the trailer
and that is Ice Cube as the main villain
Superfly a mutant fly who's looking for
mutants to officially dominate over
humans that's a little tortoises huh
they also know that Jackie Chan is the
voice of Master Splinter the Turtle
sensei and adoptive father and IO debris
who is amazing in the bear is the voice
of April O'Neil the most consistent
friend of the turtles as far back as the
franchise goes we're also gonna get to
hear Giancarlo Esposito his genius
scientist Baxter Stockman post Malone as
Ray filet a mutant manta ray
[Music]
Paul Rudd as a mutant gecko named Mondo
Gekko and Rose Byrne as a Mew and
alligator named Leatherhead now if
you're starting to think this is
sounding a lot like a Seth Rogen movie
well you're right along with serving as
producer and co-writer more on that in a
second he is actually the voice of the
villain Bebop while John Cena of course
plays his partner in crime Rocksteady
and I mean wow what a cast also can we
just talk about the fact that John Cena
is everywhere what you looking at
foreign
oh no not cool a bit cool our teen
Turtles are living under New York City
and yearning for a chance to gain
acceptance into mainstream society and
just do you know fun teen stuff like go
to high school and I guess watch Tick
Tock videos I don't know what kids do
they then meet April O'Neil who turns
them on to a dangerous underground crime
syndicate that needs to be stopped and
it gives the turtles an opportunity to
save the day and finally become Heroes
to all and of course have some pizza
well nothing we can do you guys want to
grab pizza now so far though we have
seen no signs of the main arch nemesis
to the turtles throughout the franchise
Shredder something tells me we may just
get a little taste at the end of this
one to set up the next installment but
hey what do I know oh yeah I watch
movies for a living so probably a little
bit okay um sort of a Twist well why
should I want to see another animated
reboot of the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles
it's nice I mean besides the Epic cast I
got two words for you Seth Rogen now he
teamed up with his longtime collaborator
Evan Goldberg from movies like Superbad
and Pineapple Express to co-write this
film along with Jeff Rowe who also
directed and Benji samet and Dan
Hernandez of detective Pikachu Fame I
mean it sounds like an impressive crew
and one hell of a writer's room now
Rogan who also served as a producer
wanted to lean back into the teenager
aspect of the tmnts for this reboot and
even listed the certified fresh Classics
stand by me as one of The Inspirations
behind that idea very smart it was the
one thing they never did with Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles they always had
like men in their 20s and 30s doing
weird teenage boy voices and trying to
like emulate teenagers and and so that
was really where it started was like
What if we really focus on kind of the
teenage desire to be accepted and to be
normal and this kind of like coming of
age story and and what if we cast actual
teenagers all right my friends that is
officially everything you need to know
before you go see Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles Mutant Mayhem in theaters August
2nd my name is as Perez thanks for
watching and be sure to rate and review
this film at rottentomatoes.com